[Music]
Fierce sassy ravavoom finger snapping
neck winding bootylicious realness
jam-packed with Attitude strong
independent black woman that's me right
am I doing it right
I'm asking because I often feel like I
must be doing it wrong
I must be
because it seems so easy for those
stoical wise cracking black women I see
on the TV screen
this is what's expected of me
what happens if you don't fit the mold
what happens if you're made to feel that
by just being yourself you're doing it
wrong what effect can this have on your
mental well-being Depression was
something that happened to other people
not me ain't nobody got time for that
too busy being strong and independent
working twice as hard as everyone else
and trying to make good use of the
opportunities that now presented
themselves to me because of the grit and
determination of the strong black women
who had paved the way before me
so I was shocked when depression came
for me in 2008 what was most shocking
was the realization that it had been
there for a very long time waiting in
the shadows I felt like I'd failed until
I did some research and discovered that
this is more common than I've been led
to believe
stats from gov dot UK show that four
times as many black people were
sectioned under the mental health act in
2017-18 than white people four times as
many according to the NHS black British
women are more prone than white women to
experience common mental disorders such
as anxiety depression panic and
obsessive compulsive disorders and a
recent University of Cambridge study
revealed that black women aged between
16 and 34 are more prone to self-harm
than white women
something isn't adding up here
but the data's saying one thing but
social media means and the entertainment
industry in general are still pushing
the strong independent stereotype after
I was diagnosed with depression I
suddenly became aware that I didn't see
the world in the same way that everyone
else did
that the way that I constantly criticize
myself pushed myself to Excel and was
cautious about celebrating achievements
wasn't the norm
actually that's not quite right
it wasn't the norm for my white friends
but it was normal for the women in my
family they struggled to be what was
expected of them
but instead of rejecting The Stereotype
they perpetuated it
as survival mechanism which allowed them
to integrate and build communities in a
hostile and unwelcoming environment
but at what cost I would see glimpses of
their pain and anger in private but they
would quickly hide it away from an early
age I was taught that you should never
let anyone see your pain because they
would use it against you there was a
sense that life was a battle to win you
had to work twice as hard as everyone
else for half as much reward and keep
smiling and laughing but not too much if
you were too happy then someone would
take it away from you
that's a lot right where does that
mindset come from
and how does a black woman navigate her
way through it all luckily there are
mental health organizations out there
that are specifically designed to
support the black British Community I
spoke to Jackie Dyer and Natalie creary
from black Thrive to discuss their work
so where do you think this stereotype of
the strong independent black woman comes
from I think it comes all the way back
from slavery to be quite Frank these are
some of the stories that went around in
order to help to enslave our black
population the black woman is expected
to carry the weight of the world on
their shoulder and to provide the
support and the care for others when
actually black women also need to be
cared for they need to be nurtured where
else can black British women receive
help and support take some steps and
communicate what is going on inside you
that you actually don't need to be
bearing on your own to be a strong black
woman is also to be a vulnerable black
woman I had to find somebody who you can
trust who you can talk with let's go in
to see your GP reaching out to your
social networks you need to kind of be
able to let our guard down and to say
actually I'm feeling vulnerable and you
know I need help the strong independent
black woman Trope was a much needed
survival mechanism
but for second and third generation
black women it's a mechanism that has
served its purpose
and has the potential to become a
self-destructive identity that can
actually do more harm than good I'm so
grateful for the sacrifices made by my
elders and the hardships they had to
endure
best strength will always lie within me
which means I can allow myself to be
more than just strong
out of respect for them I'm learning to
show the sides of myself that they had
to keep hidden away
it's okay not to be okay
it takes courage to speak honestly about
how you're feeling
I can be strong
and accept my weaknesses
Independence and vulnerable
move away from The Stereotype and
embrace my true self
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video